ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
special episode of coffeezilla
where we'll be roasting the worst
startups of all time
and we'll be answering the age-old
question does everything need to be
redesigned from the ground up should we
ever stop and think not can we build
this but should we build this
has silicon valley just gone too far
gonna answer all those questions in this
video but before we do
this video is actually a partnership
with our friends at mischief you guys
may remember the name i featured them on
an episode of marketing mondays anyways
long story short i guess being a sick
fan
can get you somewhere in life mom
because the mischief team actually
called me the other day and told me
they wanted me to review one of their
drops i said i'm in
i'm so excited and how much am i getting
paid they said nothing
okay slightly less excited but you know
what i freaking love this company what
they do so
i'm in a day later they sent me this
their never before newest drop
okay relax it's just a box right uh to
give some context
if you know how mischief works they call
themselves an art collective which is
like
a fancy way of saying they're a company
that's bad at making money which
technically makes me an art collective
too and mischief's whole thing is that
they do a new drop every two weeks never
the same drop
and they can be about anything and this
is their 50th drop which they call
dead startup toys and it looks like from
their website
um that it's basically an homage to all
the like the iconic startups you can see
these terrible products are in heaven
now i already recognize a few a few of
them and yeah basically they took the
products themselves and made
miniaturized versions of them
to remember them by because let's all be
honest a failure as big as theranos
will never be truly forgotten and in
conjunction with this
launch they wanted someone to roast
these startups and they picked me so
let's
let's open this guy up uh let's start
baby with the juicero
maybe we should just uh check out their
marketing real quick and remind people
what the juicero even was
making juice is easy start by taking a
stroll down to the neighborhood farmers
market buy about 50
worth of organic fruits and vegetables
don't forget to bring a tote bag dig
your juicer out from the back of your
cupboard realize there's still a part
missing
okay i think i know what they're getting
at here making juice is annoying
so okay you've told us the problem now
show us what the solution is
what is this it's a juicero i don't i'm
sorry i don't know what that word means
it's a new cereal
okay define it for me uh juicero the
best juice ever
what comes out of the juicero is so
fresh that it shouldn't even be called
juice
it should just be called i don't know
squashed produce because that's what it
is
you know what we call liquid from
squashed produce
it's juice
[Music]
our founder doug is straight up made of
juice literally there's
juice in my veins
there's juice in my veins i would have
known this thing was a fraud from the
start anyone who goes
literally there's juice in my veins that
person
cannot be trusted promise you that the
juicero team have taken care of
everything
not just the washing the peeling and the
chopping but the growing the harvesting
the washing the refrigerated transport
inspecting did we mention the washing
packaging and finally delivering to your
house
okay so actually here's the thing you
watch this commercial even now knowing
the the
ending of juicera and you're like damn
this looks this looks nice
so what's the issue right what was their
problem well basically they over
engineered themselves to the max they
have these like smart packets which
you can see on screen right now with
like chopped veggie products in them
that you supposedly
needed this fancy 400 like
machine from the future in order to
squeeze this thing right here you put
your little sustenance package in there
and it just uh
squeezed it for you but the problem is
you didn't actually need it
it turns out you could take these little
uh packets
yourself and squeeze out just as much
juice into a cup
as the machine could like look at this
is the hand squeezed one
and this is the the machine squeezed one
basically
yeah you 400 bucks to get a drop more of
juice
in your cup and honestly at this point i
mean i'm looking at this and it's like
oh this is just
pre-juiced juice with an extra step
like if you're just gonna squeeze juice
from a bag
into a cup why not just buy you know
like this
it doesn't make any sense anyway so
that's jucero guys
and here's the little miniature version
they sent me it even uh
opens up to reveal the legendary
juice packet guys that you definitely
should not be squeezing guys
wow up next we have the coolest
cooler let's take a look at the ad that
got them 13 million dollars on
kickstarter
that's the sound of a cooler coming down
off the shelf it's the sound of imminent
fun
so why haven't cooler designs changed in
almost 50 years
foreign coolers are boring break easily
and are a pain to get to and from your
destination
okay so already i already know what the
problem with this device is gonna be
it's the biggest problem with silicon
valley in general
you're always trying to reinvent
everything like the classic silicon
valley person
their big idea comes when they're
sitting at their desk and they have a
pin
and they go the pin hasn't changed in
300 years i'm gonna i'm gonna install
wi-fi in it and
change the world like no we don't need
that and we also don't need
a cooler redesign here guys but this
young founder doesn't look like he's
about to take no for an answer
i wanted a cooler that was really well
built yet had so much fun built into it
that i would look for excuses to get
outside and enjoy
so i created the coolest
[Music]
the coolest is a complete redesign of
what a cooler can be
first you've got this 18 volt
rechargeable blender you don't realize
the number of places you could really go
for a blended cocktail or smoothie until
you've got a blender built right into
the lid
all right i'm not gonna lie that's
that's cool they also said they had a
removable bluetooth
speaker coolest comes with a removable
bluetooth speaker
that connects to any smartphone to
wirelessly stream music
from up to 30 feet away they also said
it's got a usb
charger in it okay this is where it's
starting to get really weird
you're trying to design a swiss army
knife
cooler it's like installing hdmi ports
into your tire
it doesn't make any sense it's like
it's like you can do it it doesn't mean
you should do it right and that's this
whole
product it's just way over engineered
for
a basic cooler it's got led lighting
it's got tie-down bungees it's got
reusable plates
it's got a knife it's got a removable
divider
all told this thing probably assembles
like a lego set with a
thousand different pieces you have to
assemble together and it turns out well
it was
a little harder to manufacture um than
they originally
thought and these kickstart backers
ended up waiting years before
they got their product with a bunch of
them never getting it at all
basically looks like this guy just got
13 million dollars
for nothing actually i shouldn't say
nothing they actually got
investigated by the organ department of
justice
so uh that's something to put a little
feather to put in your cap there
so yeah i'd say that is well deserving
of uh
the award here of one of the top worst
startups of all time or kickstarters in
this case oh look at this thing
this little comes with wheels and
everything all right this is nice
and more functional than the actual
thing anyways that's it for the coolest
cooler i suppose
up next we have gebo the assistant
that is not amazon or google
and is probably going to fail
immediately cause of death price and
non-functionality
let's take a look at their marketing
this is your house
this is your car this is your toothbrush
these are your things
but these are the things that matter and
somewhere in between
is this guy introducing gebo right off
the top
i hate the listicle where you're telling
me what's in my life this
is your house this is your car these are
the things
that matter your family here's a 900
product that doesn't matter a robot that
nobody asked for
to spy on you all the time yo if i
wanted somebody spying on me in my
living room
i'd just ask alexa i mean why do i need
this
please explain it to me go the world's
first
family robot say hi jibo hi jibo
when was this made oh it's 2015. yeah
this is like in the
the tech optimism world back when we
thought robots were gonna help us
instead of displace us you remember
those days
um good times now it seems like they're
gonna definitely be bringing on the
apocalypse
jibo helps everyone out throughout their
day
he's the world's best cameraman by
intelligently tracking the action around
him
he can independently take video and
photos so that you can put down your
camera
and be a part of the scene take the
picture
bruh best camera man this photo's
overexposed to hell i don't know what
you're talking about
he's a hands-free helper you can talk to
him and he'll talk to you back
see grandma's carrying him around
everywhere he goes
and what is he what is he like spying on
what her recipe here
you don't have to skip a beat excuse me
and
yes jeebo melissa just sent a reminder
that
she's picking you up in half an hour to
go grocery shopping
excuse me and i can't let you do that i
can't let you leave this house for your
safety
uh the i guess this is a robot that's
going for that
like almost humanistic natural feel
which i i don't know about you i don't
like i don't like this like robots are
your friend thing
they're not your friend okay but anyways
who cares about this marketing what's
the point
well it promised to be able to like do
all these things and it got there
and was basically dead on arrival i mean
the functionality was extremely limited
it was 900 compared to amazon sweatshop
which can crank out alexa for like
a dollar and just in general it was just
out competed in
every single conceivable way and again
even with this image i'm just like
pissed off like what are you
setting jibo down at your dinner table
you're gonna hang out with jibo all the
time i
i don't get it i don't like it a bad
idea
this is the same kind of thinking that
got us here where we're mass producing
sophie the strange uncanny valley robot
to solve human loneliness but anyways
here's our
uh lovely gebo toy here oh that's kind
of cute right
look at that does this thing work like
is it voice activated
hey gebo order me an amazon echo
on amazon.com about as useful
this toy as the actual gebo and
considerably
cheaper uh up next we have the theranose
minilab ladies and gentlemen long
awaited i knew this would make it this
is a this is an all-time great
it was supposed to revolutionize the
industry of you know taking vials of
blood instead of taking whole vials
you're supposed to just get a drop and
magically this little
black box device was going to tell you
everything about your family history
and you know your vitals anyway let's
take a look at their
marketing they put together for us
people
don't even know that they have a basic
human right
to be able to get access to information
about themselves
and their own bodies that can change
their lives
i want information about your body gosh
that voice is so creepy
i want information about your body it
may change your life
what that dude every person should have
the ability
to get that type of test because if you
understand that early
that you're at risk there's a lot more
that you can do about it
i really hate to do this it's such
low-hanging fruit
she's creepy though like so oh we make
fun of zuckerberg for seeming like
a robot but this thera-nosed lady looks
like a body snatcher
even despite her running one of the
biggest frauds of all time because there
knows it didn't work like spoiler
that thing sucked it didn't work and
they actually took
vials of blood from you they told you
that they were only going to use a drop
and they used the vials as backup but
they actually ran the test by just using
like regular blood testing their whole
thing was a fraud but
it has been so overshadowed not just by
me but in the press everybody
by elizabeth holmes herself which is
quite the feat
to overshadow a billion dollar fraud
with how weird you are you know
you know hey i ran one of the biggest
frauds of all time
but the headline is like chick changes
her voice for absolutely no reason
and a bunch of other weird stuff about
her like personal life like apparently
she just lied to everyone about
everything she got a siberian husky
puppy
and told everyone that it was a wolf and
took it into the boardroom
where the dog just constantly peed on
everything
and she told everyone oh no it's a wolf
and people like that looks like a husky
anyway the point is pathological liar
weirdo apparently she bullied people
and just created a mythos for herself
that is even bigger
than the fraud she perpetuated which i
mean
hats off to you for that that is a that
is hard to do so yeah guys that's the
that's the short and long of it about
theranos i feel like you guys have
already watched 20 documentaries about
this you don't need
for me to explain to you what was a
fraud about it okay here we go here we
got the toy
uh okay it's a toy you you get the
gimmick guys right you get you get the
thing
it's a it's a little collectible now for
our next
and final startup we're gonna roast here
today
we have the one laptop per child
laptop thing apparently they had 60
million dollars in funding
and have since um gone the way of the
mini lab
now this idea i actually think much like
the juicero
is not a bad idea on paper it was billed
as a 100 laptop that was going to save
the world
how you know by giving hungry children
internet
how is it going to do that well because
there's no electricity in a lot of these
places
well these geniuses they they thought of
everything
and they designed a hand crank that
these kids who are bubbling
with free excess energy can crank to
turn on and power their reddit accounts
what's hilarious about this product is
that when they actually unveiled it
it was sort of like a cyber truck moment
because these hand cranks
broke immediately
[Laughter]
he's whining and then oh he broke
he tore it off turns out when you're
gonna build something for a hundred
dollars the materials have to be pretty
cheap
so they kind of scrap that idea and go
okay no we're gonna redesign it from the
ground up these kids
these kids are gonna charge that with
the power of their mind i guess
and so they redesign it into this form
factor where the antennas are like wi-fi
etc
the only problem is is they originally
had built it at
costing a hundred dollars and everyone
got stuck on that price point
turns out it's kind of hard to build up
anything
tech wise for a hundred dollars so they
failed
and the re-pitch is like this is the 150
laptop yeah that didn't go so well and
people quickly out-competed them
with like new netbooks and chromebooks
and all that kind of stuff
which actually had windows on them as
opposed to
you know they had some weird operating
system here so yeah a very like
tech optimist kind of idea we're gonna
give all the kids internet you know
we're gonna give all the kids laptops
that was met with the actual price of
goods
and um also was crushed by expectations
that they themselves set and that was
actually i think that's a recurring
theme
in this whole whole thing right all
these
things they set up expectations that
simply couldn't be met
and or they over-engineered
over-promised
and ultimately under-delivered but yeah
okay let's unveil the last one oh it's
kind of a
larger one that's cool oh dang that's
actually a lot of detail huh look at
that like flips out and everything
ah nice all right that basically does it
um big thanks to mischief for partnering
with this video
and now i'd like to actually review
maybe not the startups themselves but
actually the things they sent me
which are these toys so who are these
actually for because they cost
money it's like 40 bucks for a single
toy
and the collector's bundle is a hundred
and wow
sixty dollars so kind of it's pretty
pricey
and i would say that like these are not
for everybody
i think there's a very specific target
audience number one for collectors who
like limited time edition things they
only make 550 of them ever
and if you also love watching the hubris
of mankind burn itself out
um you'll probably like this but the
other people the other target audience
and this i'm actually going to tell the
mischief i mean honestly
i think the real target audience to
buying these things is actually venture
capitalist straight up like i don't know
if that's who mischief
is imagining as their target audience
and they told me that it gave me no
strings about like what i could say so
i'm just gonna review this honestly
like i don't think most people need this
but
if i were a founder or i had a company
out there and we're like
we're trying to innovate i would buy
every single one of these toys
buy them all up and give them to every
new founder
or member of y combinator you know
because that's who these neat lessons
need to go to it's not your
average person you know working in the
back of jimmy john's like you're the
backbone of this economy you didn't ask
for this right like you don't need this
in your life
the people who need this are the people
who are trying trying to install voice
assistance into everything
into a pizza box into a coffee cup right
they're trying to reinvent the wheel
they're thinking they're steve jobs
while they burn through billion dollars
in capital
they need these little toys on their
shelf to remind
them of how far too far is right like
for those people
40 or 160 that's a bargain right you're
gonna save money with this thing
you know like hey you know i was gonna
try to install
geotagging inside of a paper straw but
then
i saw theranose and i was reminded you
know by this little desk toy
that humanity probably doesn't need that
right
like boom billion dollars at venture
capital
saved from the hellfire of dead startups
but
that's basically it that's who i would
say collectors and venture capitalists
anyways if you're one of those two
people or you just want one of these
things links are descriptive whatever
you know this thing
i just thought it was a fun idea with
these bishop guys and i'm a huge fan of
their style which is why i did it yeah i
hope you guys had fun watching this
video uh thanks for watching
and i'll see you in the next one
wake up smell the coffee